a team of archaeologists uncovers a
giant ceramic vase in the ruins of an
ancient greek city they carefully brush
away the sand and debris that surrounds
it the head archaeologist grabs a ladder
and places it gently against the
eight-foot tall vas i'm gonna see if
there's anything inside he says the
archaeologist climbs the ladder and
peers over the lip of the ceramic vase
the inside is completely black i can't
see anything he shouts down to the rest
of the team he reaches his arm into the
pod to see if he can feel anything a
couple of seconds later he releases a
yelp of pain something bit me he yells
the archaeologist pulls his hand out of
the darkness and climbs down the ladder
is there an animal inside a fellow
archaeologist asks but before the
question can be answered the ceramic
vase begins to shake thousands of tiny
creatures resembling a rat mixed with a
pug flood out of the top of the vas they
start clawing and biting the
archaeologists the men run away
screaming in terror many are consumed by
the wave of creatures others are
overwhelmed as they try to scramble up
the ruins to safety only minutes after
the lead archaeologist stuck his hand
into the ceramic vas the screams are
silenced the creatures wander aimlessly
around the ancient greek city the scp
foundation hears of the incident and
sends a team to investigate they
classify the anomalous vas as scp-01
when they arrive on the scene the
thousands of creatures that were
manifested from the vas are found dead
these entities are designated scp-019-2
and incinerated before any tourists
visiting the archaeological site see the
corpses the extraction team examines the
vas itself it seems like a normal
although very large ceramic from
antiquity the scientists put in charge
of securing
scp-019 are dr light and dr vox be
careful light says we don't know what
the connection is between the vas and
these creatures it seems as if they came
out of it but our instruments aren't
detecting anything inside and there's no
way they could have all fit into that
thing anyway dr vox who is closely
examining the vaas comes to the same
conclusion they take a step back as the
extraction team prepares to put ropes in
place to move
scp-019 a rope is thrown over the vas
part of it lands on top of the lip
instantly an instance of scp-019-2
appears from the ceramic it begins
running around clawing and biting
anything it can but is eventually
captured by dr vox well
now we know where the creatures came
from we'll bring it back to the lab for
further study the doctor says he hands
the creature off to one of the agents
the ropes are secured and the team
begins to move the vas but with every
moment another
scp-019-2 instance appears from the
artifact
this is gonna get really annoying says
dr light let's put the whole damn thing
in a mobile containment chamber and let
those little creatures run on top of
each other rather than us chasing them
around agreed replies fox a containment
pod is brought in the team quickly moves
scp-019
into it as instance after instance of
scp-019-2 manifests from the vas the
doors to the pod are sealed light and
vox watch hundreds of small creatures
run around inside they bring the vas
secured in the containment pod back to
the scp foundation site where it can be
studied further it is transferred to a
containment chamber where it is observed
by light and vox after a few days
scp-019 slows the manifestation rate of
the
scp-019-2 creatures when the vos was
first secured agents were ordered to
shoot the creatures on site but the
number of bullets being used was
unreasonable so they resorted to
flamethrowers the doctors decided the
best course of action is to put scp-019
into a room hooked up to an incinerator
this way if too many creatures are
manifested they can all be burnt to a
crisp with the push of a button dr vox
can't help but think that this must have
been what captain kirk felt like on the
starship enterprise when it became
infested with tribbles eventually it is
discovered that as long as scp-019 is
kept at zero degrees celsius and no one
goes near it the object only manifests
one creature per hour this is much
easier to manage than the hordes of
scp-019-2 instances that came out of the
vaz previously doctors light and vox
observe and collect data on
scp-019 through a glass viewport that
looks into its containment chamber the
incinerator is turned on at least every
24 hours just to clear the room of
creatures when they are not working with
the vas itself the doctors examine
scp-019-2 entities to try and understand
what they are and what they want they
capture one of the creatures and put it
in a reinforced pen light and vox
provide the specimen with live chickens
for food and as much water as the
creature can drink the noises that
scp-019-2 makes sounds like muffled sets
of words when linguists are brought in
they determine that the vocalizations
are phonetically similar to ancient
hellenic languages this is consistent
with what was spoken at the ancient
greek city where the ceramic vas was
found the doctors gave the specimen a
series of puzzles to solve it can make
its way through a maze to find a piece
of chicken but when it is given
opportunities to show its sentience
scp-019-2
always falls short dr light and dr vox
determined the creatures are about as
intelligent as lab rats one of the most
peculiar things is that
scp-019-2 instances only live for less
than 48 hours no matter how much food
water or care is given to the creatures
they drop dead in a day or two after
being manifested dr light moves one of
the dead critters to an operating room
where it can be dissected she cuts down
the middle of its stomach with a scalpel
and peels the skin and muscle away well
that explains that she says to the other
researchers standing in the room the
muscles seem to degrade rapidly from the
instant
scp-019-2 is manifested into our world
there is basically no digestive tract
other than a mouth and throat the most
surprising thing is the complete lack of
internal organs dr vox pushes the
intercom button from the viewing room in
which he is observing the procedure what
do you mean there are no internal organs
it must have some sort of brain and
cardiovascular system
yeah but that's about it dr light
responds there appears to be a very
simple central nervous system with a
brain the size of a pee and a heart but
nothing else
this creature can't metabolize the food
it eats or filter out toxins and i have
no idea how it breathes we need to run
more tests with each new specimen that's
examined the results are the same the
creatures aren't very intelligent they
die in under 48 hours and they lack
pretty much any internal organs then one
day everything changes for the worst the
guard posted to watch over scp-019 notes
something strange occurred during his
shift without fail the vas manifests an
instance of
scp-019-2 every hour but around 3 am no
creature was generated or at least
that's what appeared to happen the guard
puts on protective equipment and enters
the room to get a closer look but there
is nothing there he locks up records the
anomaly and returns to the viewing glass
to continue his watch over the next hour
the vaz manifests a creature as if
everything is back to normal the next
day light and vox arrive at work to find
everything in chaos the power in
different sections of the facility is
failing it is as if something has gotten
into the ducts and is chewing through
the wiring a team of agents uses thermal
imaging devices to track down the entity
that is causing all the mayhem they
bring it back to the research lab take a
look at this the agent says pointing at
an empty operating table he hand stocked
her light his thermal imaging goggles
without them there appears to be nothing
on the table but when she looks through
the device she can see an instance of
scp
scp-019-2
my god dr light whispers they're
evolving the creature is exactly the
same as all the others except this one
is invisible suddenly an alarm goes off
and red warning lights turn on across
the facility light rips off the goggles
and looks at dr vox we need to get back
to the voz now she yells they sprint out
of the operating room and down the hall
as they turn the corner they hear
gunshots in the spray of fire from
flamethrowers on the other side of the
corridor where scp-019 is contained
there are agents battling with thousands
of instances of scp-019-2
the flamethrowers that had been so
effective at killing the creatures now
appear useless it is as if the creatures
have evolved some sort of protective
skin to combat the flames oh no gasps dr
light we gotta get out of here she grabs
dr vox's shoulder and drags him with her
as she runs down the hall behind them
the scream of agents can be heard they
are quickly muffled as thousands upon
thousands of
scp-019-2 creatures overwhelm them light
glances behind her to see what is
happening what she finds is a wall of
creatures rushing towards her there must
be millions now it seems like scp-019
was tired of being contained by the
foundation and has sent an invasion
force to escape its captors we're not
going to make it
he stumbles and falls to the ground dr
light skids to a stop and turns to go
back for him but it's too late the wave
of
scp-019-2 is closing in she watches in
horror as dr vox is consumed by the mass
of creatures she turns and continues to
run the exit is in sight dr light makes
a dash towards the door she can feel the
tiny feet of the creatures clawing at
her heels she gives it everything she's
got and accelerates putting some
distance between her and the millions of
scp-019-2
entities dr light slams through the exit
door and immediately closes it behind
her she manages to slide the metal
locking bar into place the impact from
the wave of creatures against the door
sends her stumbling backwards she is
safe now as light lays on the ground
panting and staring at the door she
thinks to herself well though i'll be
dead in a couple of days and then we can
try again now watch scp-000
which is the real zero zero one scp
animation or check out scp-823 carnival
of horrors scp animation